Reggie Miller on the call for the Sixers
Pacers Thursday night that's at 7:00
Eastern on TNT reg also part of TN t--'s
blockbuster MLK Day tripleheader the
Rockets in the 76ers also that day
features the Warriors and the Lakers at
10:30 Eastern good morning reg how are
you good morning theater now coach
Boeheim he's been around a long time and
he has seen a lot of body types fair
comparison of Sir Charles in Zion but
two totally different players number one
Charles did not have the explosiveness
that Zion has but on the flip side
Zion wasn't a not yet not yet cuz he's
still young Charles would absolutely go
through you on a break and was a little
bit more refined score so that still has
yet to be seen in Zions game but he can
develop that I think Charles was a
little bit ahead of the game in terms of
that 6-4 6-3 6-4 and I'll be generous
and give him 65 type player that could
dominate a game at both ends of the
floor but let's face it they they would
they weren't cut Charles wasn't cut but
he was strong he was country strong as
we call it but if I said you could have
Charles Barkley's career knowing what he
did you're gonna have a Hall of Fame
career or I give you the unknown of Zion
Williamson what would you take I would
take Sir Charles I would take Sir
Charles it's career um yeah because
knowing that I'm gonna get the Hall of
Fame player I'm gonna get the MVP LED to
organizations in Philadelphia as well as
Phoenix there's a lot of look I'll sign
is gonna put people in the in the stands
and in today's age our social media
that's huge
so I like the upside I still don't know
in today's games you've got to be able
to shoot and
that's something that is still the big
question mark on Zion the game that he
had you know 30 and 15 or whatever last
week that we talked about he made three
threes before that he had made four
threes all year so there's a little bit
of an inconsistency with his jump shot
but again that's something you can add
you can't become better at that Michael
Jordan wasn't a great jump shooter when
he entered elite became a really good
jump shooter so that's something that's
a part of Zions game that will be added
I believe later to go along with that
Pledis ISM and I think that's gonna make
him a much more complete basketball
player if I could if you had the ability
to play sion williamson with an NBA team
for the betterment of the league what
team would you put him on well I think
that's gonna it's really going to come
down I think it's gonna look a lot like
the frozen card the old myth that it was
one of those weighted down balls that oh
my god the Knicks got Patrick Ewing I
couldn't you just see Zion turning that
franchise around I mean an electrifying
electrifying player the most logical
thing and if you're looking to turn
around a franchise obviously it would be
the Knicks but I would love to see him
in Phoenix with Devin Booker and Andre
Aten I mean you know they have they have
corner pieces there so I could see them
in Phoenix as well James Harden head but
yes something else range well is it
funny couldn't you also see him falling
to Cleveland LeBron they get Kyrie
Irving LeBron might want to go back
LeBron would go back to Cleveland
surprised if if the cab got him as well
harden scored 57 last night so that's 17
consecutive games with at least 30
points how much longer can he keep this
up
well you're gonna have to keep it up a
little bit longer with Clint capela
being out at least a month with the
thumb injury that what he's doing no
Chris Paul no Gordon now no cappella and
he's still finding ways with double and
yes I would probably send a triple team
Adam to score 57 points I mean it's
phenomenal what he's doing and where
they started they were 14 out of 15
teams in the Western Conference I'm a
month and a half ago and the stretch he
went on in December and he's currently
on here in January it is phenomenal
and he's got three key components out
and he's still fighting ways to score
the basketball
and they're winning they currently set
forth in the Western Conference it's
phenomenal what he's doing right now
he's my MVP I think he's talking on the
door because of what he's done but if he
can continue this and they could find a
way to get a three or four spot this is
again the best score in today's rules
maybe that we've ever seen I was
wondering this I was watching some
highlights of Luca Don Schick I have a
lot of downtime on my hands just letting
you know so I'm watching some highlights
of this and I started to wonder who
created this step-back jumper that's a
good question it's been around awhile it
was a big part of my offensive
repertoire I kind of adopted it or got
it from Kiki Vandeweghe for me CLA he
taught me the step back jump shot but
it's been around forever because you can
clear space but if you would look at
Luca and if you look at James Harden
understood James Harden step back is
more of like a side step as a poetry
that's back yeah he's going to the side
which makes it very difficult for the
defender that's why he's getting so many
four-point plays because usually a step
back is what what is named for you're
going directly back Harden and Luca they
step back to the side so when you
recover you're going right into their
body which is allowing you to get those
four points
ways but it's been around a while the
step back this step to the side that's
that's something kind of new that's been
on the scene lately and James Harden and
obviously we're seeing the rookie looka
donkeys reap the benefits of that yeah I
was wondering because I thought of you
and that Kobe wanted to study that move
in the offseason one offseason with you
I don't remember keke vanderway being a
step back guy for some reason even great
score I just what great score and yeah
he had a heck of a step now it wasn't as
deep I shot my step back from threes his
was more a mid-range step back but he
could absolutely go left or right with
those step backs a phenomenal score and
I was like Kiki I gotta have that we
think countless hours in the gym during
the summer day really I'm up with that
stuff and I just extended it to the
three-point line and then Kobe when we
were doing that one-on-one shoot with
the world world and we had some downtime
and we you know he wanted to play
one-on-one I'm like I ain't playing this
kid one-on-one but when we were messing
around he's like I got to have it I got
to have it and I gave it to him and lo
and behold he used it against me son of
a yeah yeah well but everybody borrows
from everybody I I think but Dirk
Nowitzki created something that we had
not seen before with his jumper where he
has sort of a step back but his leg is
up into the defender a little bit there
he's probably the creator of that isn't
he he is and who adopted that Kevin
Durant right so you're right everyone
everyone steals or adopts or take
samples tries to modify samples and
tries to modify it into their game and
what makes dirt and Kevin so lethal is
both players are you know borderline
seven-foot and both have long wing spans
so there's absence of all they don't
need to do it because you're not going
to be able to block this shot anyways
for creating that distance with
being right in front and what made Dirk
so difficult he would catch that like
right around that free-throw line area
top of the key there was no way you
could double him because he could see
where I was coming from and he had
shooters on the edge and then at 7 feet
a beautiful touch one of those shots
that arguably one of the toughest shots
to guard against could you to help Lonzo
ball of this free throw shooting wrench
like there is no reason a point guard in
the NBA
shoots 42% from the line we said that
and we saw Rondo I mean yeah two point
guards on your team that can't see
free-throws that it's a little baffling
to me because wasn't that the thing that
he was supposed to be working on during
the offseason was his jump shot in his
confidence in his shooting it's got to
be better I mean as a point guard it has
to be better because he's a liability at
the end of a game like Shaq was where
you can't so the guy who's going to have
the ball the most I can't have him in
there because he can't make free throws
you said it that's it and and there's no
excuse for that for a point guard really
because you are the team you're the
floor leader you're the team captain and
the balls in your hand 90% of the time
other than one level Ron James is out
there who's not a great free-throw
shooter himself so you've got LeBron and
you've got
Lonzo both guys who are counted on to
win ball games for you their suspect at
the free-throw line
yeah and I think that's why Luke Walton
has made a decision if you look at those
close games down the stretch
Hanzo is not on the floor and it's
because of as you just mentioned being a
liability at the free-throw line
in your last season in the NBA you
missed a total of 18 free-throws in the
entire year Lonzo has missed 20 of 48 or
28 of 48 already this year I think he
but it's gone now more towards it's
becoming more mental for him every time
he goes through the line it's one of
those you're running away from the
basketball because you don't want to get
fouled
yeah and it's become more mental every
time he steps to the free-throw line
and I guarantee you the opponents know
that and they're going to exploit that
yeah gotta get in the lab brother gotta
get in the lab and work on that if I
gave you 20 free throws blindfolded 60%
I will go 16 I would succeed now I would
yeah because once you get your rhythm oh
yeah yeah I think you might do a little
better than that Ridge oh I know but you
were a great free-throw shooter but you
put the time in to become a great
free-throw shooter you know that's what
wait those are wasted points if you're
gonna if you already true score and you
really want to punish the defense you
can't miss four you know those are give
me it's hard enough to score especially
at the professional level
and they're giving you points you get it
you gotta take advantage of that but I
can't have Steph Curry shoots a higher
percentage from three-point range with
somebody guarding him then Lonzo ball
does from the free-throw line with
nobody guarding him reg that's crazy
also Paulie said something yesterday
that surprised me because I said you
know what we forget how great Steph
Curry is he had 48 the other night
against Dallas and it makes it look a
little too easy like we've moved on from
Steph Curry that fascination Paulie said
he would take Steph Curry over any
current NBA player right now he's a lot
like Michael Jordan and Larry Bird in
this sense he changes the way you
gameplan for the Warriors when he was
out for those 10 11 games and it was
just Kevin Durant and clay and dream on
very difficult to play KD is a load full
and a problem but for coaches when Steph
is healthy and they're all together the
game plan changes because you've got to
pick up you know 60 70 80 feet when he's
on the floor because he's liable to
shoot it from anywhere taking roles
with him you can't switch you you try
too hard hedge you try to go over you go
under he knocks down three he has such a
weapon he changes the whole landscape of
your game plan and that's why when
they're clicking and rolling and when
they get boogie back on the 18th which
I'm curious to see how he's going to fit
in offensively with this team
it's a different dynamic when Steph gets
it clicking and gets it going because he
stretches stretches everyone's defense
to the max before you could kind of load
the paint a little bit and back off on a
few look away and sometimes I Katie but
when Steph is out there your defense is
to the max because you have to extend
everywhere and on top of that he's great
without the basketball
so he's constantly in motion he'll give
it up and just keep running and it makes
it very difficult for the defense
reg will be on the calls Sixers Pacers
on Thursday night at 7:00 Eastern on TNT
with Kevin Harlan also part of TN t--'s
blockbuster MLK day triple header he's
got the Rockets and the 76ers also on
that day warriors Lakers at 10:30
Eastern reg safe travels going to check
in with you thanks for joining us as
always these are debts you're the best
I'm going back to Indiana on the song by
the way
on Thursday I will kiss the ground for
you it was when you me you and Mark
Jackson and that smoky bar we had our
our come to Jesus moment this was
fantastic during the final four it was
that moment I was like Theodore we are
we're together we're gonna be together
forever my friend but we you and Mark
Jackson didn't agree on anything
no like Tyson Holyfield merino Montana I
remember and you guys looked at me like
I was gonna decide which one and then
when I would pick one and then you then
the other guy would be yelling at me and
I remember smoking cigars having some
drinks and you guys were so excited
about that conversation because
ask you this one man only go in versus
rod carew who you going with this was
this is our big one that we always used
to get into it so you're going with Tony
Gwynn Rod Carew Tony Glen talk to you
later
you're the best thank you read judge
Reggie Miller for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]